you want to be a millionaire one day
you're on a Ferrari or Lamborghini maybe
a penthouse maybe you want to marry a
model maybe you want to be a governor
cover the magazine what do you want what
do you want what do you want I can act
the whole notebook scene for you what do
you want today we're gonna talk about
what you need to do to plot your next 50
moves based on what you want okay so
enough for this notebook reference let
me get right into it on what you need to
do with your next 15 moves now this is a
reference of another video I did think
like a Grand Master but I'm gonna get
into a little bit deeper today so look a
lot of people have big dreams but I
think the processing on how to go about
doing this most people don't have an
idea what to do this is why I do the
vault conference once a year where we go
three days together the next one we're
gonna have it it's gonna be in July in
Florida if you want to know more details
about it be down there but there's a lot
of stuff you got to go through questions
feelings to really get clear about this
this is a glimpse let me give it to you
on how I think on how to plot your next
15 moves the first thing you got to do
is your massive life course what do you
want your life goes to be you literally
have to sit by yourself I'll give you
the PDF and start writing them
everything I just said you want this you
want that you want this you want even
recover Time magazine business magazine
Forbes office what is it you start
making a list of all those things it's
the first thing you do number two is you
eliminate what you can live without you
may say I'd like to have a Ferrari I
can't live without it I'd like to have a
penthouse I can't live without it
I cannot live without a lakefront
property because I love fishing because
I grew up fishing with my dad and when I
finish my grandpa when he was alive we
used to go for it's anymore I have to
have it then you have to put that on the
list right so you eliminate whatever is
a small little want and a desire that's
exciting but doesn't produce that you
send you right next identify the top
five things you cannot live without so
you go through this list and you say um
I got to be a governor one day
I got to be President one day you know
what I got to have that house I got to
be a millionaire I got a memory model I
I just whatever your five are doesn't
matter what anybody by the way somebody
may say well it's so snobbiest so you
know self is self righteous for you
don't want to lambo it doesn't matter on
what other people say what moves you so
you make that list right and then the
last thing is the key this is the part
most people struggle with now these are
not small goals this is not I'd like to
lose ten pounds I'd like to you know go
from a size seven to size five whatever
maybe these are not small stuff these
are massive life goals we're not talking
small stuff massive life goals I want to
be an NBA champion I want to be a
millionaire I want to be a billionaire I
want to go into politics
it's got to be massive right but this is
the problem for most people the problem
for most people is step number four
here's what step number four is list
them by sequence not by desire which
leads to which meaning you may want to
go out there and do movies or produce a
movie
it may not be step number five it may
not be step number one it may be number
ten it may be number eleven you're
eventually going to do it but you have
to get your sequence right you may want
to be a governor one day but it may be
step number thirteen
it may be step number twelve it may not
be step number three you may want to go
out there and get a lake house one day
it may be step two or step three
whatever it is you got a list which
one's your number one like what do I
need to go after first that leaves me to
the second and the third and the fourth
and the fifth and the sixth two often
you've heard me say this before too
often we get to you know ambitious
ingredient we put number eleven to
number two and then we lose everything
and then we start again today I had a
couple people that were with me very
well-known body builders and we were
mapping out and and the husband and wife
were here and we wrote out every single
project I have going on every one of
them and and they're saying how
frustrated they are because everything's
going good but nothing is going great
these are the killers these are not
regular people we plot we wrote out
everything there then I said here's some
bad news for you what's that you got
eliminate some of these what do you mean
I got eliminate some of these which one
of these can you live with that
because you got to cut this cut this I
said what's your number one then we came
out with the number one I
to go out there and think about it this
weekend and say what do you want what do
you guys want to make me your number one
that's why this is a key thing so I'm
gonna spend a little bit more time in
this because you have to know what your
number one massive life goal is to
achieve natural number 19 you're number
one number two thing you got to do whose
life do you want to model now typically
when you hear this a lot of people may
say I don't want to model anybody I want
to be one of a kind I want to do it my
way I get it
even a trump who did it his way he
modeled after somebody else's life a
part was is that a part was his mom you
know his mom was very foo-foo she always
look at all this stuff and as that was a
business kind he had a couple other
people in the marketplace that he saw
that he want to look after right even a
rock who did a speech to the Lakers said
his game plan when he went to was the
agency says look here's who I want to be
he says I want to be Will Smith
even though Will Smith's part of this
agency agency I just want to do it
bigger matter of fact here's what he
said share this with you guys and Will
Smith is my boy and I sat down at that
time with the agency I was with they
said what do you want to accomplish I
said I want to accomplish the world I
want the world and I want I want Will
Smith's career but and I said I mean
this respectfully because I know he's
here at this agency with us I want to do
it bigger and better
and they looked at me like I had three
[ __ ] heads and they were like mm-hmm
okay but I still stayed focused and I
still had these still put in the hard
work with my two hands pretty intense
right I mean those are some bold goals
to say I want to be like Will Smith
except bigger and to even say that this
is what I wanted to do so who do you
want to model so once start off by
listing names okay here's one guy maybe
this guy maybe this gal maybe this girl
maybe this couple maybe this person
maybe whatever it is make a list then
then kind of figure out which ones are
the ones that you wanna you wanna have a
combination of somebody may say you know
I want to be a little bit of this a
little bit of that a little bit of this
no problem mix them up whatever maybe
mix them up on who you would like to
model then you need some homework you
got some homework here's what the
homework is you got to go study the
route they took to get there what does
that mean number one who did they shadow
who who would they a you know tutelage
of who were they working under would
they had a chance to watch somebody
write well what route did they take with
their first 15 steps meaning not their
last 15 steps their first 15 step when
they decided to go out and pursue this
what did they do you may need to read
some articles book about them stories
about them to really kind of identify
what they did next who was in their ear
very important who was in their ear the
names of people that was in their ear
it's different than they shadow shadow
somebody I'm watching right Rach saw his
dad he was a wrestler he shattered his
wrestler rock had his uncle Simone he
kind of watched what they did football
all these you know people have certain
people they shadow but this is who's in
your ear who is influencing them then
it's their strengths and weaknesses
their biggest fault their biggest
victories and I had they recovered from
a fall that they had what was the route
that they took that's to study who's the
life you want to model next one so you
already made a list of your massive
goals you already made a list of who you
want to model you know what the third
one is here's what the third one is the
third one is taking a pause and
visualizing this is gonna be you your
life your massive goals who you're going
to be what you're gonna do with your
life
pause turn off the phone turn it around
put it down turn off the TV get away
from everybody and just sit there and
visualize and say does this fire me up
does this get me excited
that's a produce jus
does it feel like I just had ten cups of
coffee does it make me cry with smile on
my face you know the kind of crime
talking when you're smiling on your face
not to cry like you're having a hard
time were you crying like man this is
exciting right if you get to that state
then you're working on the right place
if you don't get in that state you got
to go back up again because you're just
kind of doing it as if it's high school
homework you really got to put some
effort into this um think about it this
may take a week or two a few hours for
you to go through it can't just be
something you do so now again making us
your big life goals whose life you want
to model how does it make you feel what
do you need
meaning when I say need it's a few
different things what kind of people you
need in your life one who do you need to
shadow what kind of customers clients do
you need what advisers do you need in
your ears
what believers do you need to find
believers or somebody that believes in
your like somebody that fully knows
you're going places you need believers
in your life right even a minimum of one
that fully believes in you you need
believers in your life and number five
is enemies you're going to have some
enemies are you okay with that it's
better to know up front they're gonna
have some enemies you know I got a text
earlier from somebody today and this
person said he's a influencer on social
media you know who he is any messages me
and he says I have a concern talking
about politics on my channel and my
concern is I have to get over it because
I have this fear that people gonna say
bad things and it's gonna backlash and I
don't want that right and my response to
this person was I like this guy a lot
he's a very likable guy I said first of
all I don't think anyone is anyone's
gonna have that from you because you
come from a curious place and number two
if they are you know they're gonna have
it's gonna happen but you got to be
comfortable with that
however the point is enemies if you're
not comfortable having enemies you're
probably not going to be doing too big
of a goal you have to understand that
your family may be an enemy your exes
may be an enemy your next employee may
be an enemy your your ex friends may be
some enemies but you have to be
comfortable with that part most people
have a hard time again what you need
people next skills people skills sales
networking social media marketing
negotiation what is it you need some
skills write them down next tools you
need some tools what our tools phones
technology software there are certain
tools you need resources money content
how do you get better context how do you
get access to your money mine said you
can't have a start-stop you get excited
you come back you start you can't do
that so you can't have them mentality
you start you finish or thicker skin you
know you got to get hit from a lot of
different angles you got to stay tough
so dear sir these are some of the things
you need you also have to kind of figure
out what kind of a person you need to
become for that to happen that's why I
wrote here mindset 5 vehicle to get you
there what do I mean by vehicle Arnold
use bodybuilding ok Rock use wrestling
I'm using financial industry or
insurance I got into it and then all of
a sudden boom look what takes place
everybody has a certain vehicle that
they use what is the vehicle you're
gonna be using Arnold use bodybuilding
for 15 years it wasn't like a small
order thing and then movies business
Kennedy's all of these things but you
gotta use what to whatever kind of a
route you're gonna take and last but not
least there's potential threats
potential threats could be what marrying
the wrong person ok somebody you marry
their console like oh my gosh you're not
here you're always doing this I can't
believe this you know he's the your
whatever what is that all about why's
she keep calling you why is he keep
calling me that that's Dragon Bay I want
to do something big
Oh bold pulling you back down you marry
the wrong person forget about all this
other stuff okay you have to make sure
they bind to this kind of stuff as well
and you stay firm with your dreams
competition you know you have to know
that you're gonna have some competition
going there right success one of the
biggest enemies you win you will
typically forget about this when you
start winning oh you know let me tell
you you know let me tell what happened
what happened when you were all excited
about the stuff you were crying oh you
know that stuff I doesn't matter you
know it's a different story today I'm 37
years old today I'm 35 years old today
I'm 52 years old today I'm sorry you sat
in that chair you cried when you talked
about this you know it's called maturity
no no it's called giving up on the big
massive life goal so he so you're hiding
behind the money and small success that
you got it's okay
a lot of people do it but when you
talked about this and you asked the
question does this fire me up I remember
the look on your face you got the chills
your tears okay you were biting your
nails your foot was going that day you
were all over the place because you were
you let a little bit of successful you
with this come on man come on let's get
back at it again right running out of
money getting bored wrong people in your
ears and last but not least forgetting
where you came from so you got a
rillette it definitely spent some time
think about where you came from because
every time you win every time you win
more people tell you how special you are
you need to go back and say don't forget
here's what I used to be don't forget
this is what I used to do don't forget
you sir every time I go to LA I like to
visit where I lived I enjoy it because
it reminds me this is you for nearly a
decade every morning on Christmas Day in
LA we would wake up at 5 o'clock and go
over there just to say look man this is
this is this is some stuff that's out
there man I'm the luckiest man alive to
be living in the greatest country that
mindset of being a lucky comes from
knowing where you came from and feeling
grateful even as you're getting new
successes and going up and then last but
not least you get you got to kind of
keep that part of mind that you have no
other choices if you're constantly going
well you know if this doesn't work out
I'm gonna go over here if this doesn't
work out I'm gonna go over here if this
doesn't work out what you are not doing
in that same speech that rock gave
talking about the fact that he wanted to
be
Will Smith except bigger he says I go
based on a wall I got a wall on my backs
against the wall that wall with back
against the wall mentality produces the
sink-or-swim you got to make this thing
work even if you got a hundred million
dollars in the bank you still got to
have that feeling of you're broke you
got to have that feeling that nothing oh
my gosh but I've got to make this thing
we're using that same brute you cannot
get soft once you start winning having
said that again this is just a few
minutes of me giving you an idea by the
way just so you know this we do this and
go through case studies at the vol
conference once a year I do this and
it's not just a bunch of stuff that you
come through and take your own notes
this is a manual that every by by the
way this is a trademarked manual that
everybody gets one day attend of all
conference and this year is we're gonna
do to Miami if you haven't yet register
I'm gonna click on the we're gonna put
the link below somewhere go click on the
link below I think it's July 6 through
the 9th we have a lot of different
sessions that will have at this even a
lot of different speakers some of the
sessions will be sealed with me and
founders if you want to have the private
session with myself there's gonna be
about 100 something people that will be
with me that's questions back and forth
and then the session will be nearly
4,000 people
in Miami so if you haven't yet register
click on a link well if you wanted a
speedy PDF what I just covered with you
if you want today's PDF send a text if
you're in us if this is outside of us
you will not be able to text us 3 103 4
0 1 1 3 2 once again 3 103 4 0 1 1 3 2
or if you want the PDF you're out of
this out of state you can simply go on
the link below we'll put a link below so
before the PDF click on that put your
email in we'll e-mail you the PDF as
well you'll have access to it print it
out go through the entire process again
you may want to watch this video again
to kind of get back in your mindset when
I was going through here you may want to
watch it one more time so we want to
watch it again and if you haven't
subscribed to the channel please do so
take everybody well bye
[Music]